welcome everybody to ask doc live so
glad that you're taking aaron out of
your schedule
and
hold on hold on
[Music]
all right now dr wallach you're going to
have to unmute yourself
so
we are
here for a stock live thank you so much
everybody for joining us today taking
time out of your schedules on friday
whether it's well for some of you it
might be saturday actually but taking
this time out with us on friday to
um be a sponge and learn about
alternatives that can help you in so
many different ways
so many different ways my name is
rebecca kozak i will be your host for
the next two hours we are here i have my
wonderful co-host ruth ellen sanchez
who's going to be helping me with
the waiting room and making sure
comments get addressed and for those of
you who are on live you'll be able to
turn the chat on and
chat as it's going through and catch
names of products and all that good
stuff
but
this program is brought to you by
askdoclive.com
but i want to make sure if somebody
invited you to this program specifically
get back with them if you have any
questions in regards to products and
wanting to get a protocol that's
specifically designed to meet your needs
the person that invited you to this
program
they care about you so we want to make
sure
that they know that you're interested in
improving your health and being
empowered as well
for those of you who are not invited to
this program by anybody specific you
received
an email or you're part of our
newsletter subscriber base we thank you
love you
and you can always do a reply to that
email with questions or at the
askdoclive.com website there is a
contact us
and that will get an email directly to
one of our certified holistic health
coaches that can help you get your
questions answered and that's including
our
business opportunity so we're going to
talk a little bit about that
it's an amazing way to add some a little
bit of or a lot of extra income
while you're doing something that's
purposeful and much much needed in a
time that we're going through right now
so the content of this program is to
provide educational information only and
it is on the importance of nutrition
you know so many different things in our
life is affected by deficiencies and
when you correct those deficiencies the
body can do some amazing things and not
just survive but thrive
this program is not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician and
the fda requires us to let you know that
our products are not meant to treat
prevent diagnose or cure any diseases
now
we're really really honored
and to have this program
that we
welcome and invite one of the co
well it's one of the founding fathers of
a theory called epigenetics and
epigenetics has basically proven that
genetics just don't exist that we can do
things in our environment and in our
diet that can change all these things
that
matter modern medicine has diagnosed or
said as genetics just because they can't
explain it and
dr wallach is here as
one of the founding fathers of
epigenetics where he has taken his own
research
and proven time and time again that
genetic conditions can be
not part
of your family's future so dr wallach
thank you so much for being here with us
we appreciate you so much
and we look forward every friday to
having you here and sharing wisdom with
us so what do you have to start out
today for us
well just you know a little bit of news
here before we get into the subject of
the day
um this coveted thing is spiking again
this um delta variant from india
is really going crazy and um let's see
right now
this is last night's figures
um
the
united states we have 38 million 643 113
um
infections
we have
let's see here
um
dead we have 643
1113. now that's interesting because
during the spanish flu we had 657 000
dead
and um
we're not too far away from that i think
by by the end of this month we will have
surpassed the spanish flu which was
horrible
and of course india had at that time 20
million
dead in six months 20 million dead in
six months
and 110 million infected in six months
and so um this is very scary stuff
and it all has to do
with being susceptible to the bugs uh
why are we susceptible to the bugs that
was there's several things a lot of
people
they don't want to get vaccines well
that's their choice
then a lot of people get the vaccines
and they still get the covet infections
and still die well how can that be
they're vaccinated well vaccines don't
kill the virus or bacterial fungus or
ease they just notify your body about
bad
dna and rnase when the bug shows
everybody says ah there is the bad guy
and you send in your defenses you send
in your white blood cells including the
t lymphocytes which kill any the viruses
and the antibodies which kill the
viruses
and bacteria and so on
and red blood cells and platelets which
protects you from bleeding to death and
all that kind of stuff
and so
you need to have the nutrition so you
need to be supplementing with all the
essential nutrients right now
you want to go with a heavy hammer the
healthy brain and heart pack that has
215 nutrients in it you want to stay
away from all the bad stuff
you can maximize absorption of these
things no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens no wheat bar ionos no
sugar no carbon or drinks
and
even the diet one's got to go because
it's still got the carbonation
neutralize your stomach acid so you
cannot digest stuff and your stomach is
not sterile when it becomes neutral or
alkaline your stomach has to be in a
um acid environment to be correct
then
uh let's look at a couple of the top
three states when it comes to
covid and then we'll get into the
subject of the day
uh number one is california
um with 39 million people california
with 39 million people um let's see here
california has
4 million 176
infections
and just short of 65 000 dead 64 842
dead
second is texas with 28 million
almost 29 million people 28 million 955
uh in uh population
uh texas has three million four hundred
thousand and four
infections
and fifty four thousand
almost fifty five thousand fifty four
thousand eight hundred sixty two dead
number three is florida they're getting
hit hard florida was twenty about 22
million
people
they're getting hit hard they're running
on the average
000 to 25 000 new infections per day
okay and they went over there the third
state to go over three million
infections right now there are three
million
um
988 infections
and 41 931 dead
well when you look at california
texas and florida
they're
45 to 50 percent latinos
blacks and indigenous peoples so half
or more of their population or those
three races
and it's a dietary thing it's not a
racial thing it's a dietary thing
because they live on wheat by the rhinos
they live on gluten which kills your
intestines so you cannot efficiently
absorb nutrients even if you're
supplementing even if you're
supplementing you cannot absorb these
nutrients if you're eating gluten so
clean up your diet get rid of the gluten
no wheat butter and oats no fried foods
no processed meats no oils
no sugar no carbonated drinks take your
215 nutrients get with a big hammer that
held the brain in hard pack
and then we have killer biotic we have
the
fucoid z
we have our colloidal silver which i've
been taking for 25 years put two
droppers full under your tongue
30 minutes before
each meal and 30 minutes before bedtime
it takes two of these four ounce bottles
a month to do that
and then you want the hand sanitizer i
go through four to six of those little
bottles depending on how often i go in
out of the house
or a hand sanitizer i put it on my face
i put on my neck my arms up to my
shoulders down to my hands and fingers
my feet up to my knees
and um
when i leave the house
when i come back in i do it all again
throw my clothes in the basket and put
on clean clothes
and so you have to be very very
uh what should i say
um proactive here in defending yourself
especially if you choose not to get the
vaccine
now people say well there's so many
people getting the vaccines they still
die from covet what's going on well
they're not supplementing they're eating
gluten
and
the vaccines do not kill the viruses
vaccines only alerts your body to the
bad dna and rna so you're responsible
for being prepared to deal with it when
the bug comes
well if you're eating gluten your villi
are gone your intestines instead of
looking like a shag rug looking like a
smooth plastic tube you've lost 98 of
your absorptive surface you're not
supplementing
and see you have to appreciate that
plants do not make minerals
two-thirds of the 90s essential
nutrients are minerals plants do not
make minerals
plants make vitamins
you know like vitamin c they make some b
vitamins but some of the
grains that make b vitamins you don't
want to eat like wheat rye and oats
okay and so you really have to
supplement because you have to avoid all
these bad foods then
you'll be in better shape to
live well kids are
even if they don't die you know at three
years old from getting covered they they
can transfer to grandma who can die
and so you want to get the kids tidy for
them you want to get the efas
don't forget the
the pollen bursts of pollen burst shoes
um which are berries and
and um let's see here uh
they're they're berries oh and the efas
they have efas here uh in in the
polymers um the the efas come from
sunflower seeds
and instead of wheat brown around oats
so i i like pollen bursts for kids
because that tastes good individually a
little wrap
bars like inch long and quarter inch
thick
and then of course replacing
the
if i can mention something about the
polymers dr walick excuse me for a
moment so the pollen are full of
antioxidants
and they are really yummy so especially
if you have somebody that has a hard
time
taking supplements that's one way you
can get antioxidants and efas
in a yummy like starburst type form so
i just want to make sure everybody know
that that is something that's available
as it's not taking the place of the 90
by any means today definitely help you
for sure
thank you
okay okay well one more thing here and
then we'll get to the subject of the day
flexi care plus
this takes the place if you're old
enough to remember having bone broth
the chicken bones beef bones sheep bones
turkey bones fish bones you'd leave them
simmer in vinegar water on the wood
stove overnight and then you'd argue
who's going to get the biggest serving
of of the um bone broth in the morning
and people got collagen and calcium and
stuff like that that way
well we don't have wood stoves anymore
for the most part we don't have
bone broth and so this is formulated
based on what was in both broth bone
broth and it tastes good it has a lemon
lime flavor
plexi flexicare plus
and it has msm in it it has vitamin e
for the muscles and then it has of
course calcium and
uh all that kind of stuff
uh and collagen in two farms so
add that and taste good add that to the
liquids especially for kids
and especially for grandma and stuff
like that
well the subject of the day we want to
talk about the heart
the heart never stops working when
you're asleep you're sitting at your
desk reading or working is it's working
uh when you're working is working when
you're doing extraordinary things like
exercise or something is really working
and so the heart
it works every second of your life
from the time
you're conceived to the time you die
so you really want to think about it we
need to take care of the heart well the
heart requires 90 essential nutrients
there's a couple of nutrients that are
particular
particularly
required for the heart
and when you don't get enough of this
you die suddenly uh it's called
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy heart
disease this is what causes these 500 to
a thousand young athletes to die every
year in america alone every year they're
in good shape through the you know
they've lettered three years in a row
they're going to be on the olympic team
and they come home from exercising that
day and they're sitting at the table
eating dinner and they dropped it
from hypertrophic cardiomyopathy heart
disease okay kind of thing well
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy heart
disease
is called keyshawn disease in heilum
zhong province because keyshawn
university is here dr milan with all her
connections in china
got me to do a project in china where i
did 1 700 autopsies on kids under the
age of 10 who had died of
ketone disease hypertrophy
cardiomyopathy heart disease
okay 35 of them had cystic fibrosis 100
percent had muscular dystrophy
100 of them would have been diagnosed to
sediment syndrome here in the united
states
and so i actually for doing that
published in three languages mandarin
cantonese and english
and it was um i i got the um
clown schwartz award for that i got
nominated for a nobel prize twice for
that study
and
it it
which i say just um
helped us get the fda
to approve putting that nutrient into
baby from zinfandel and similac because
none of the babies who died instead of a
death syndrome were laid on by their
mothers 98 were in the crib when they
died
and the two percent that were in bed
with their mothers i went back and redid
the autopsies on hundreds of them and
guess what oh they died of hypertrophy
cardiomyopathy heart disease because in
the baby farmers they were getting
because they weren't being breastfed
they didn't have that nutrient in there
because doctors kept telling the
manufacturers that nutrients toxic don't
put it in there
well after that 1 700 autopsies
nobody could
you know
could come up against me
with the answer to that so they
forced the manufacturers to put that
nutrient in their people said what is it
what is it well no you just you don't
have to take that you know take the baby
farmers we're going to do that you need
the even for newborn babies if they're
going to be on baby farmers you want to
add the
kid's toddy to it okay add the kids tidy
to it
and that's that has the nutrient in
there as well but it's by law it's in
those baby formulas now and we don't you
don't hear about scissors anymore you
don't hear about musculoskeletal anymore
they actually fire jerry lewis when
jerry lewis brought them all this
information was from the muscular
dystrophy association they should all go
to jail for that firing jerry lewis and
shutting down the telethon you got to be
kidding me he raised two billion dollars
for them
and
over 20 years in the telethon and when
he brought them the cure
they fired him
and so they should be ashamed of
themselves they should all go to jail
and they should shut down they should
shut down the unless they change their
ways they should shut down the
um must risky association then son of a
death syndrome i'm the guy that made him
change the name to crib death because 98
of the kids that died have said in the
death syndrome died in the crib they
were in bed with their mothers the
mother never laid on any one of them
but doctors say those things when they
don't know what the answer is they blame
it on somebody else with your genes
oh
it's autoimmune your body's attacking
itself oh the mother laid on the baby
that just is interpreted to i don't know
what the heck it is and so i'm going to
blame you
i don't want to be embarrassed
i will never say i don't know because
god is my second that's what doctors
think they're bigger than god and so
that's why
dead doctors don't lie was so popular
because everybody knew what i was saying
was correct don't forget
the surgery was success
but the patient died
so why did he do surgery when it wasn't
necessary well because he had tuition do
for the kid his kids
for college
so
this nutrient for this heart
is one of 90. and so you don't want to
be just taking that you want to be
taking it with all the other 89. and
right now you want to be taking the 215
with a big hammer out of the toolbox
now the heart also has congestive heart
failure
it's a simple vitamin deficiency
congestive heart failure for the most
part
and so you get rid of all the bad foods
you take the 90 cents nutrients
and um you can throw in the de-stress
capsules which has a lot of that one
nutrient and within weeks congestive
heart failure you've had for a long time
goes away
hybrid pressure uh coronary artery
disease
okay coronary heart disease it has
nothing to do with cholesterol
it has nothing to do with cholesterol
the blockages of those arteries coronary
arteries is due to eating salad
dressings and fried foods
cholesterol makes up 75 of your brain
weight when they came up with statin
drugs
they came up with statin drugs to lower
your cholesterol because they mistakenly
believed
that cholesterol is blocking your
arteries and your heart and your brain
and your kidneys and every place else
um they created a new disease called
alzheimer's disease now don't get me
wrong there's been dementias going back
to the bible days senile dementia and
many others
occasions when people had scurvy they
had also dementia because you didn't
just get one vitamin deficiency you're
on the boat eating salt pork right
eating salt pork and bread that's gluten
and salt pork everything bad and so
uh and they weren't taking any vitamins
and minerals
except for the salt sodium chloride
but that was only two of the 90.
okay and that's why these people they
lost their memories they had dementias
and they went they would die of scurvy
and bleed to death and all that kind of
stuff
so
um
this is this is nothing new
um also when a baby's born
rebecca how old is the baby when it's
born
well most babies are nine months old
yeah nine to ten months old nine to ten
months old so you're only you've got to
give them credit they're almost a year
old when they're born
okay so people need to be taking these
90 essential nutrients to protect the
heart of that baby
for at least six months before
conception
all through the pregnancy
and uh all birth defects are preventable
there are no birth defects there are
genetic there are no birth defects that
are autoimmune
and of course that's where the
um epigenetics came from
as my thesis which originally was 5 000
pages it represented
20 000 autopsy it was a 25 million grant
from
the national institutes of health
i did the work at washington university
at the center for biology and natural
systems in st louis
and um it's in the smithsonian institute
my thesis is in the smithsonian
institute as national treasure because
they showed there were no genetic
diseases there were no genuinely
transmitted diseases and there are no
genetically transmitted birth defects
it's all nonsense
i take people who were like
halfway through the first three months
of pregnancy and the baby's got down
syndrome from a three screen test or an
ultrasound
and we give them give the mother the
supplements
and the babies are born perfectly normal
the most famous one is lauren knievel
evil knievel you know the daredevil guy
his niece-in-law
and she had a an embryo it was diagnosed
with a three screen test and an
ultrasound as being a down syndrome baby
two and a half months pregnancy we gave
her the 90 twice a day
and the baby's born perfectly normal his
name is noah knievel
and um i have some wonderful pictures of
him you know he graduated engineering
school
he's a very handsome guy in the military
and you never in your wildest dreams
believe when he was an embryo he was
diagnosed with down syndrome because
when he was born he didn't have down
syndrome anymore because we were able to
reverse it in the early embryonic stages
with supplements
now you know once the baby's born down
syndrome you got what you got but then
we have a wonderful couple
the name of um
ben and wendy herdman
uh they were both born and down syndrome
kids and their parents didn't know each
other uh but they all kind of moved to
texas about the same time they were i
don't know probably 50 75 miles apart
they never saw each other until the kids
got in grade school
but they started putting them on the
youngevity products for kids and 90
essential nutrients
and they're a beautiful couple now and
of course again
ben is an engineer
and those two they help so many people
around the world
ben and wendy
and when you look at them
you never guess that they were down
syndrome because they just look
perfectly normal because they've been on
these supplements
and they're in their late 40s now but
they've been on these supplements since
they were like three four five six years
old
and so it's an amazing thing which your
body can do when you give it the raw
materials to fix itself that includes
the heart now there are some things
um if you're born with a hole in your
heart
because you weren't getting the right
nutrients
it depends on how big that hole is if
the hole as big as a pinhead well i'd
give it you know a couple of months on
the 90s sense of nutrients and it might
close itself if the hole's as big as a
dime
it may require surgery
but that hole wasn't caused by bad genes
or autoimmune it was caused by mama was
missing stuff when the heart
was forming the four chambers and all
these big arteries coming out of it and
the little arteries feeding
the heart muscle and so forth and all
the valves had to be formed it's a very
complex organ it never stops working 24
7 for your entire life from the time
you're consider you're conceived all the
way until the time you die
and so
um you really really
um we can eliminate all heart to birth
defects
we can eliminate them so you don't need
surgery
when people have
um
this
again congestive heart failure coronary
artery disease give us 90 days before
you do
uh coronary bypass surgery you know
and they
cut loose the arteries off your heart
and rearrange them and stuff like that
that's very scary stuff
and then
you have these valve problems when the
heart enlarges the valves don't grow
they're made out of connective tissue
like tendons
and so the valve leaves don't meet
properly and so you get all these weird
noises when the heart is beating because
the blood is coming back up where the
valve is supposed to prevent that from
happening so before you go for surgery
you're like say 12 15 20 30 40 50 years
old and you've had this problem now give
us 90 days and get on the healthy brain
and heart pack
and that heart will tone up so now those
valve leaves will meet and do their job
again
and most of the time you won't need the
surgery
because you just had to tone up the
heart muscle because it was missing the
nutrients
and it was getting fat and flabby
because it wasn't getting the nutrients
you're getting a little bit of that one
that
when it was deficient causing you to die
of hypertrophy cardiomyopathy heart
disease sudden heart death so that's why
you're still alive
but um
there's
um probably about 25 different heart
diseases that are preventable and
reversible
which is nutrition
and supplementation
and so think about that just remember
the surgery success but the patient
died so dr wallace i have a few
questions and a few things that i want
to kind of um reiterate with what you
said okay
blockages within the heart
are not you're talking you're talking
about you're talking about the arteries
right within the arteries
so
they're not caused by cholesterol
that's correct in fact
isn't cholesterol kind of like the
band-aid within our blood so when
something is going wrong within
it it can be used to patch arteries but
it doesn't build up and and cause
blockages
uh well i wouldn't even say that
uh cholesterol
the
cholesterol has several jobs
uh number one for me it makes up 75 of
your brain weight is cholesterol
makes up most of the white matter your
brain
secondly
it makes up 95 of testosterone yahoo
that's why you three eggs twice a day
okay makes up 95 percent of the weight
of testosterone makes up 95 of the
weight of estrogen progesterone and
women say yeah my ob gyn says i need to
have some estrogen i need to have this
because i'm not making enough estrogen
well
um how many well i'm on statin drugs
because my cholesterol was 200. my
doctor wants it down you know below 150.
well
the the optimal cholesterol level in
your blood should be of the good
cholesterol it should be 350 to 500 they
want you to get below 150.
you're going to get alzheimer's disease
which did not occur until
1960.
alzheimer's disease didn't exist it's a
very specific
disease causing a memory thing but it
didn't exist until 1960.
because everybody's eating eggs and meat
and all that kind of stuff since the
beginning of time
whether dinosaur eggs or
robin eggs or something or you know
people were eating eggs and they were
getting the cholesterol and so we didn't
have that just like obesity obesity was
not a big problem
um
until
after 1882
prior to that everybody in the
industrialized world were skinny
well when 1882
we went from wood stoves to electricity
and there was no more wood ashes
minerals to put into the gardens and put
in our food
people began to gain weight because
mineral deficiencies cause people to
have a behavior called pica
people began to gain weight and doctors
made the biggest mistake of all they've
cost more lives than all the waters in
the world put together since beginning
of time by saying this statement give up
animal fats and eat more whole grains
well these people started eating wheat
and barley rhinos like crazy
but what was it that the egyptians were
eating during the ten plagues for the
ten years they're all dying like flies
well for a thousand years before that
they were eating rye
and barley and wheat
gluten alert gluten alert gluten alert
that's what's going on now with our
pandemic with the covid everybody's
eating gluten because doctors said eat
more whole grains and everybody thinks
that wheat and barley and oats is good
for you
no
they're the worst possible things you
can eat that's why the asians do much
better than us when it comes to the cove
because they eat rice and sweet potatoes
and beans and squash
also good for the heart
and so um this is not difficult
but you have to say
um
okay well i'm going to try something
else for say
60 days and see what that does to my
blood pressure i want to see what it
does to my blood sugar i want to see
what it does
for you know
for my weight
and everything begins to come right when
you get off the gluten and take the 90.
okay so
we have somebody that um has problems
with infraction
like 30 33 infraction whenever it has to
do with the blood flow
going in and around the heart
what would be used to
help improve that dr wallach okay well
when people have you know partial
blockage of the coronary arteries
again they got to change their diet no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat no brother i know no
sugar no carbohydrate or drinks even the
diet one's got to go
and then um they need i'd put them on
the healthy brain and heart pack one per
hundred pounds of body weight and then
specifically to support healthy blood
flow through blocked arteries and to
support healthy blood pressure and help
bring the blood pressure down which they
tend to run together
i want them to take per hundred pounds
of body weight
three of our ultimate daily classic
tablets twice a day and that will
support healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries even if you even have
95 blockage they'll support healthy
blood flow through those blocked
arteries and support healthy blood
pressure
don't cold turkey off the blood pressure
medication when you get on our program
but you know take your blood pressure
every day and as your blood pressure
slowly comes down you can slowly reduce
your medication for blood pressure based
on the numbers like you've been taught
to do
and this is so again this is not
difficult and that's why we have
we we have all these books and cds and
dvds uh a beginner what you want to do
is start out
of course we have the gluten issue
that's a big issue because it prevents
you from absorbing things even if you're
supplementing
and so this is a three year study
with three professional chefs in canada
and myself dr wallach's
cooking without the bad foods
okay
dr wong's cooking without the bad foods
300 pages of gluten-free recipes
300 pages okay and i'll read this to you
this is from the chief of these three
professional chefs a chef norman
he said i have worked in the culinary
industry for well over two hours for
well over 20 years when i first
encountered dr wallach's food
recommendations i believed it was
impossible to cook that way in the food
industry oils and glutens are ubiquitous
well fortunately i'm quoting him now
fortunately i was wrong in the last two
years we have recreated every dish i can
think of
without the forbidden ingredients
okay
so every you know this is a chef who has
a reputation
who is putting together this cookbook
based on your food recommendations
that's correct i love that
yeah so this is this is a study we did
for three years and of course i was
working on the recipes with him and
these three chefs are working in
restaurants when they're on tv
and so we did we did um
uh questionnaires all the people eating
my diet
did you like the taste how did you you
know how'd you feel about it and then uh
you know
respond to us in two weeks and four
weeks and six weeks let us know how your
blood pressure is and this and the other
and how your digestion is how your bowel
movements are and the response was so
great it freaked these three
professional chefs out because they
couldn't believe it they thought i was
some kind of freak and i was a million
miles off base but people have been
eating this way forever yeah since those
10 years of plagues in egypt right
eating wheat brought around oats that's
why they had the plagues just like why
we have the pandemic
same principle no immune system
okay and so
then of course we have let's play doctor
let's be herbal doctor passport chrome
therapy it's all in your head the 25
diseases from osteoporosis is the skull
doctors never talk about that
and then the new one wallock's cooking
doctor walks cooking without the bad
foods
those will cover 300 different diseases
those five books the quintet of books
will cover 500 well 300 for sure
different diseases and tell you how to
prevent them how to reverse them with
nutrition and supplementation so you go
to www.drjwalik.com
www.drjwalk.com that's w-a-l-l-a-c-h
and you know there's volume discounts
when you buy 10
of the books you get discounts when you
buy a case you get discounts
and
this is something that everybody needs
if you want to add 25 to 50 health years
your life and you've heard me say this
many times rebecca is our goal at
youngevity is to add 25 to 50 healthy
years everybody's life we can do it we
know we can do it we've done it all over
the world
and we've been doing this for over 50
years
we have people who we started with
uh who were in their 20s and 30s 50
years ago
and you know now they're my age i'm 82.
i've been gluten free for 74 years i've
been taking the 90th century
nutritionist for 74 years a couple of
months it'll be 75 years
and so it's kind of um exciting
most people think i'm in my 50s when
they look at me i can't believe i'm 82.
and you know varicose veins go away that
you're
it's a red warning like varicose veins
it's not a disease it's a nutritional
deficiency the same thing that causes
varicose veins
it causes white grey and silver hair
white green silver hair is not due to
aging
okay it has to do with nutritional
deficiencies and you know the story
about michael jackson he died of a
ruptured eric aneurysm at age 51 and he
had the first symptoms of that
deficiency
when he was like
six years old he was a very dark skin
black kid but he started getting these
little bean sized white spots all over
him called vitiligo when producing
enough
of the pigment for his skin
and the doctors told his parents well
this is genetic thing there's nothing to
do about it you just put some makeup
over that or let him wear gloves or
whatever so that's why he started
wearing gloves all the jewelry on it and
then he started putting um
every morning he would put um tattoos on
his face
so that people would think that all this
his
white skin on his face was makeup
okay because his face was as white as
typing paper
and his hair started going white so he
was wearing wigs
and then at age 51 he dies or ruptured
artic aneurysm because that same
deficiency that causes
this loss of skin color hair color
and varicose veins that same deficiency
also caused a breakdown of elastic
fibers in your arteries you dive a
ruptured aneurysm either in the heart
the ar to the brain something like that
and so um
arctic
aneurysms aneurysms or coronary arteries
these things are totally preventable
totally reversible
and so before you do surgery you know
give it 90 days you know you're 30 years
old you didn't just get that you've had
these things for a long time so another
you know a couple of weeks or a couple
months or so not going to make a
difference
on the bad side but it will probably
make a good difference on the good side
because those aneurysms will repair and
slowly go down to the normal diameter
and caliber of the arteries
so
let's let's go to like the beginning
stages or even just being diagnosed with
an enlarged heart
yes
okay well in large heart could be again
due to congestive heart failure okay
that's
it could be due to
deficiencies of many nutrients uh
particularly that one that caused the
sudden heart death hypertrophy
cardiomyopathy heart disease
and just like you know you get muscular
dystrophy you get muscular history um
in uh in animals
a six-year-old kid who lives on a cattle
farm already knows the answer to much
recipe because in a cattle farm you sell
muscle you're selling beef muscle for
meat right and so when all these calves
would die from what we would call
muscular system kids
um
we learned a long time ago when i was a
kid that you give them this one nutrient
and that's you know they couldn't walk
they would lay down and scream in pain
we try to pick them up make them stand
up you know they had what was called
white muscle disease white muscle
disease in calves and sheep
and chickens and turkeys
and pigs and llamas and everything else
is what oh must just be in humans
oh so it's genetic in humans but it's
just a simple nutritional deficiency in
animals oh i see
[Laughter]
yeah no that i mean that right there dr
wallach is totally against common sense
in my in my book anyways well it is it
is against common sense and so
again
uh doctors should have some
um they should
which i say there should be some global
payments made from the medical
associations in the medical schools to
the parents who have lost kids to
muscular history
okay and cystic fibrosis and sediment
death syndrome
and of course um it was first it was
it's very common it used to be common in
turkeys
where they would die suddenly from
hypertrophy cardiomyopathy heart disease
it was very common in calves and race
horses oh my gosh you can imagine the
athletes of the animal industry grace
horses they would die of hypertrophy
cardiomyopathy heart disease
and you know that's where we learned you
know what deficiency caused it
because you know you have a two million
dollar racehorse you don't want them
dying because you didn't give them 25
cents worth of something every day
okay this is not difficult
and so um
the medical system owes a lot of people
a lot of money
for
the knowledge was there
they just didn't take the time or energy
or effort because they're making too
much money treating these people every
day every week every month for years and
years and years and years and putting
their kids through college with this
money so why would they want to stop the
flow of that disease
okay
and so um
same thing with you know most of these
diseases we have today are totally
preventable they're totally reversible
but insurance pays so the doctors don't
feel guilty
about
billing you
because and say well it's not hurting
the patient because insurance pays
but see that's a silly attitude well no
i take that back it's a criminal
attitude
and so that's why i came up with dead
doctors don't lie
that's why we've sold more than we're
pushing 700 million sold now
of the cds and dvds i have to look it up
and see how many of the books are sold
it's in the millions
dead doctors don't lie there you go
the book is in spanish and english
the cds and dvds are in nine languages
okay all over the world and so
it goes into these things
this was i was trying to get the word
out to people hey try these things for
90 days
okay and of course they used to say some
terrible things about native americans
back when the when the
european
uh settlers came here the united states
you know what 400 years ago they said
some very very terrible things about the
native americans i don't want to repeat
them and i i was going to use those
terms against the doctors but it was too
strong so i reduced it from whatever
that was to
dead doctors don't lie you can probably
remember what it was they used to say
about native americans
but it was too that was too heavy
so i reduced it to dead doctors don't
lie
oh and and for those of you who are
joining us on this program you can find
all of dr wallach's most popular books
on our website as well
and including on his website
our website is ask doc live
and
dr wellick
jim made a comment here in the chat that
goes
right along with a lot of what you say
but she says you do a good job
educating people but people i know don't
want to give up gluten fried food sugar
etc they would rather take a magic pill
insulin and complain
she says and though i try to tell people
about taking vitamins and minerals
they'd rather waste their money
okay
this goes back
to the beginning of time
and of course you know even in the time
of moses and jesus all the great
healers and great
religious
people from all the different religions
all over the world there were people who
got it and followed it and lived to be
lived to be 300
lived to be 600
lived to be 120
and there's a lot of people who didn't
want to believe it and didn't care and
they died at 20. and so everybody makes
their choices and of course it's a
matter of eliminating
the people who don't pay attention to
the details
and
so um
uh it's one of those things where
um
people make their choices
and so they got to live and die with
their choices
and so we give them we give everybody
the information equally and you know
these these shows are free it's not like
they have to pay us to watch or listen
to this zoom right they can get on for
free
and so
it's one of those things where we're
giving them the information
and if they choose not to take it it's
their
is their choice
is their choice this goes back to the
beginning of time
and
they're people who don't listen to god
so i don't feel bad about that we've
done our part by giving him information
and it's a matter of
selection of the fittest survival of the
fittest
whether it's attitude choices
or speed you know how fast you can run
away from something wants to eat you all
those things
okay
um add to your ability to survive or not
and so when people make their choices if
you choose poorly
and that was in one of those old indiana
jones movies you know when somebody died
from something simple he said well he
chose poorly
and
and yeah
well and we're here to help provide
information and be a resource to you
we hope that you find the information
valuable
and what we do what we share on our
programs and
we encourage you to share
our programs we have the replays you can
find all of those on askdoclive.com
and you can use those videos to help get
the information out to your family and
friends that there are other options
you don't have to depend on a chemical
because folks our bodies are not
chemical deficient
they're nutrient deficient and the body
itself was it's
magnificently designed i mean think
about it we come from tiny cells within
our mother's eggs to what we are today
i mean how is that not a magnificent
creation
and when we support it and give it what
it needs it continues to thrive
and i love that i am no longer barely
surviving dr while but i am thriving and
it's all because of your message
and somebody shared it with me well
thank you so much
for sharing with everybody else you know
you're beautiful not only physically but
you're beautiful in spirit because
you're helping so many people you're
taking a lot of time and effort on your
part to help a lot of people
and you and ruth ellen and sema and john
t and your whole team and we just really
love you guys and gals and it's one of
those things where
again we're putting information out
there
and
people should grasp it i mean what a
gift
25 to 50 healthful years
okay and we're talking about just a
couple of bucks a day less than a cup of
starbucks coffee
um
per day
uh to add 25 to 50 healthy years your
life and if you do this as a business
that
money you spend on your own supplements
uh is tax deductible because in your
business plan which is in my book called
wallach street wall street for kids
wallace street for kids abbreviated to
wall street for kids
and it
teaches you how to build a business plan
to where your business plan will pay for
your
health insurance and it becomes
tax-deductible you get to deduct the
amount of space in your
that you're using in your home for your
business whether it's your office your
warehouse and your your conference
center and all that kind of stuff
let's say it's 25
of your
floor space and let's say your mortgage
is uh
2 dollars a month in your home or your
rent is a thousand bucks a month so 25
percent of that would be tax deductible
25 percent of your utilities are tax
deductible 25 percent of your homeowners
or renters insurance is tax deductible
uh people who come in to maintain your
house or your yard or is 25
tax deductible and so if you use 50 of
your home then everything is 50
tax deductible and you can get thousands
of dollars a month worth of tax
deductions
even before you start making a lot of
money with your youngevity business what
if you're making
uh say
fifteen hundred dollars a month worth of
tax deductions for three months that's 4
500 bucks in tax deductions you're gonna
get back at the end of the year
okay is that crazy
i think it's fabulous i love it
yeah and that didn't count how much
you're spending that didn't that didn't
count how much you're spending on your
personal insurance
and also your supplements i'm just
talking about the home use okay
yeah absolutely that's a it's it's one
of the greatest investments i think i
have ever made um because now i can
enjoy life where before
i didn't want to see the next day
which is sad
you know
but hey let's be real folks
there's so much that we can do
for helping out ourselves and our family
it's just a matter of having the
knowledge
and putting it into action and that's
what we're here today for
so dr wallach let's go ahead and get to
some of the hands before we go okay
the first person that i'd like to call
on is lorraine
lorraine go ahead and unmute yourself
hello lorraine hi dr wallach thanks for
your time
okay so i am uh 63
and i weigh well i weighed myself this
morning i was 117 but i don't know if
that's accurate because it's usually
124. oh that's close that's close enough
okay and so about three four months ago
i got diagnosed with asthma
and um they're telling me
that there's a hiatal hernia and it's
causing acid reflux and it's causing
asthma
and so i'm thinking um polycarp and
montelukas
okay well stop there do you have any
skin problems any eczema dermatitis or
psoriasis
no
okay do you have any bowel problems
constipation diarrhea irritable bowel
syndrome celiac disease crohn's disease
[Music]
i wouldn't say constipation maybe slight
but okay all right um let's see here do
you have any blood pressure diabetes
no
do you have any gray hair you're wearing
a wig or coloring your hair
hair color yeah i have gray hair
okay do you have any varicose veins in
your legs
yes yes okay so you have a hair
oh hang on like so i've been having a
lot of chest pains they keep doing all
these cardiac tests and they can't find
oh well here well here's why
because the same nerve that's been so
you have osteoporosis of the skull
you also have
asthma it could be copd it could be copd
or it could be asthma it could be both
and do you have any do you have any
heart stuff any irregular heartbeat or
fast heart rate or high blood pressure
no high blood pressure sometimes yeah i
have like um irregular heartbeat
okay no they they did a bnp and d dimer
and it was very slightly
okay okay and so basically there's 12
pairs of cranial nerves and when the
10th cranial group the vagus nerve gets
squeezed you get irregular heartbeat
called atrial fibrillation that's
probably what they were looking for afib
is quite common in people your age 63
years old atrial fibrillation is that
10th cranial nerve being squeezed by
your skull when you have osteoporosis of
skull do you have any ringing in your
ears any tinnitus you're ringing in your
ears
yeah on my left side you know they
checked
but they said i didn't have that but
yeah my ear on the left side yeah
tinnitus okay well that's the auditory
branch of the atrium that are being
squeezed by your skull when you have
osteoporosis in the skull
and so if you don't do something about
it you're going to get bell's pulse
you're going to get trigeminal arousal
you'll slowly go blind are you losing
vision over time
no i mean i can see you know he's
talking about my right eye keeps
twitching
okay well that's a different story okay
okay all right so okay and so here we go
117 pounds you need to get off all the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
meats no oils no glutens no wheat no
broth around those no sugar no carbon or
drink eat like an asian rice sweet
potatoes beans squash
yeah i've changed my diet quite a bit
okay now i want you to well quite a bit
isn't good enough it needs to be totally
you need to do it right totally okay
then you need to take one healthy brand
heart peppermint get another bottle of
marcelinium not from all greens or
the grocery store our selenium has these
five cofactors in there
oh and one healthy branded heart pack
will have one bottle of selenium in it
so once you get another bottle of flame
because i want you to take six a day
take three at breakfast for dinner or
two three times a day for a total of six
a day right now really fast
well they're gonna post this
yeah you'll be able to listen to the
replay at askdoclive.com
okay
okay then you can um
also
uh take in in addition to the healthy
brain and heart pack that extrapolated i
want you to take the msm get one bottle
of that so you can take three of those
twice a day and that'll support and
promote maintenance repair cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between a vertebrae bone makes you
including a skull
okay and your hair color will come back
um your veins will go back to normal and
your asthma will go away
the reflux can be caused by the same
uh squeezing that same nerve the tenth
cranial nerve causing what's called
gastroparesis is severe doctors say oh
you have a you have a
stomach ulcer so they put that tube down
your throat and look around in there for
an ulcer and they're always disappointed
when they can't find it because it's
really called gastroparesis you can look
that up gastroparesis it's a squeezing
of the 10th cranial nerve the vagus
nerve
and you get this irregular heartbeat
called atrial fibrillation which is not
really a heart collar it's a skull
problem
so asthma will go away very quickly when
you take what i just told you and so
don't submit any surgery or anything
like that and don't pull turkey off your
medication until you've been on our
program for you know a couple weeks or
10 days or something you're noticing
really improvement so then you can kind
of reduce your medication by ten percent
and then if it's still going if still
everything's getting better you know
another week reduce another ten percent
and so on so take a month to wean off
your medication don't just cold trick
your medication when you get our
products but everything you have here
will go away
by getting rid of all the bad foods and
taking the program i just laid out for
you and
again
um as rebecca says this is posted and so
you can go back and you can listen to it
a thousand times if you want to and but
do call us every two weeks because your
story is gonna help a lot of people
people between 40 and 70 middle-aged
people like yourself
these are very common things and they go
to a doctor and after about six years
time they're on 6 8 10 12 15 20
different prescriptions they're going to
the doctor twice a month
and don't worry about insurance pays
no
these are all red warning lights and
there's something worse coming along
here if you don't deal with it okay
okay
okay okay lorraine
all right thank you lorraine
now again everybody go to askdoclive.com
you'll be able to find the replays there
you also have a store there where you
can purchase products if you have never
[Music]
spoken to
anybody about the youngevity supplements
the store is available for you there if
you have been referred to this program
yes
i don't think uh lorraine was done
she was still talking
oh i didn't see her mouth still moving
i'm sorry lorraine should i take the
start pack
no the healthy start pack is in the
healthy brain and heart packages the
healthy brand hard pack has 215
nutrients in it of the 215 nutrients 90
of them are in the healthy shark package
okay
is the core of the healthy brain heart
factor that's a good question
okay thanks very much dr william i
appreciate it okay well that tells me
you're very smart because you asked that
question very good
yes very very good
um so dr welch let's go to the next hand
that is up and that is susan
go ahead and unmute yourself you are on
live with dr wallach
hello susan
good morning good morning and thank you
my first um
i
first i want to say thanks
i i've been on the product for six or
eight months consistently every day and
i want to say i have felt better i just
did some exercises with my 11 year old
granddaughter and i not only could keep
up with her but i could do things she
couldn't do so
i was really excited going i've never
been able to do these kind of squats and
jumps and things so it's all because of
your products dr wallach and well thank
you for the feedback super grateful um
also i have a couple of questions one is
i i believe my hair is turning darker
and on the other question i haven't
heard you say this before but it seems
like i'm growing more hair is that a
possible after oh oh yes um i had people
who are uh
i mean bald like a bowling ball smooth
like a bowling ball doesn't have a
single hair on their head for 40 years
okay and and just um say two months on
our program they're growing their hair
back in six months time they have a full
head of hair with the original hair
color when they're 12 years old and so
it freaks everybody out and they say do
you have implants or what's going on
here no i just take this supplement well
yeah i noticed i i brush my hair and
there's no globs of of hair in the brush
anymore so much there was before so
i am loving my progress i'm 76 years old
five foot three i think i've lost about
a quarter of an inch to half an inch
um and i weigh 146 pounds however i have
a problem i've been no gluten for a long
time for years
and i've been on the 90 of course and
much much more i ate three eggs twice a
day
i got a problem
i'm in a situation where my family had
an emergency and i had to come and take
care of people and it's a household full
of gluten it's like
i feel sick i mean i feel
not comfortable okay now my question is
i know something's going on because i'm
getting a gluten alert um how do i do
blocks from that when i go home
what do i do to like
change that is there something wear a
mask
wear a mask wear a mask oh while i'm
here
okay where am i asked
okay
buy these you know
disposable kind of like
plastic gloves and just the real thin
ones not heavy-duty work plastic gloves
but you know just these little
uh like surgical type plastic gloves
okay and then um
when you wash your clothes in their
washer and dryer you
you run a load with no clothes in it
first and have the soap clean out the
um laundromat okay
so that you're not washing even even if
you're not washing your clothes with
theirs there's still gluten gonna be in
there unless you run you just run
a cycle you know with the soap in it or
at least the bleach or something and
before you put yours in there
oh a great answer
same same way with the sheets and all
that kind of stuff you cannot be
washing your sheets in the same load
with theirs
right
right thank you that's really good the
other okay i have one other question is
that i have consistently not every night
but i've been having severe cramp in the
left big toe
i i do have some spider veins that are
going away but i still have them and i
sometimes get leg cramps that just wake
me up in the middle of night there's
something i can add or something i'm
doing wrong in terms of the supplements
is something
did you ever have sciatica did you ever
have low back pain or anything like that
i got it i got it constantly yeah yeah
okay well what i want you to do is i
want you to add the flexicare plus to
your
supplement program
this is like
okay flexicare plus and this is
chemically like bone broth you're old
enough to remember bone broth oh yeah
okay
okay well this is formulated to replace
bone broth that is very difficult to get
anymore or produce anymore and so this
takes the place of what bone broth did
was a source of minerals and things like
that
to rebuild your disc
okay you might even regrow an inch or
two okay
rebuild your disc and rebuild your bones
and you know this could be called hammer
toes or you know whatever's going on
there um but these things it's due to
your back issues okay okay because of
that yeah and so don't forget your
collagen don't forget your glucogen yeah
every day
okay but but then um this has a month's
supply it's got 60 ounces
which gives you an ounce twice a day for
the month and so you can take an ounce
of this in your breakfast supplements an
ounce of this in your dinner supplements
okay so there's one bottle last a month
so i always buy two or three at a time
so that i never run out
and you know i'm 82 years old most
people think i'm in my 50s when they
look at me
they can't believe that i'm
82. because i mean i everything i do is
rebuilding something
yes
yeah absolutely can i ask one more
question i have a customer i'm one of
your distributors i've taken the
coaching course and she's pregnant and
they're seeing anomalies in the baby um
she's 26 or 28 months pregnant uh weeks
pregnant sorry
and what can she do extra to help that
fetus at this point in her pregnancy
well we i don't know what anomalies mean
it just means something's going wrong is
it an irregular heartbeat does he have a
hole in the heart does he have down
syndrome
it's they don't know for sure they've
done the sonogram they don't know for
sure but they know that she's missing a
finger
and uh well i can't regrow the finger
it's too late for the finger okay
i can't regrow the finger but the mama
should be taking do you know how much
she weighs
i would say she's probably weighs about
um okay
okay she's under 30. okay i'd have her
is she going to breastfeed the baby
i'm sure
yeah okay then she needs to start taking
two healthy abandoned heart packs per
month
bulldoze everything twice a day
and her take the fucoid z through those
twice today those are capsules from
algae and that kind of stuff
and then i would also have her take
again this flexicare plus she can take
an ounce of this twice a day
okay
but uh but that's gonna give a lot of
nutrition to that baby but she's going
to stay away from the gluten so she can
absorb it no wheat no boiling around
oats no wheat nobody rhinos no wheat no
broth around oats okay
urgent okay
i'm on it thank you very much dr wallach
yeah let us know how the baby does i
will she's gonna yeah when she's born
i'll make her have her make a reporter
i'll come on and make one thank you so
much god bless god bless thank you
awesome thank you so much susan so dr
wallach let's take a quick break
everybody thank you so much for hanging
in with us we will be right back and be
getting to the hands that are raised
here with us live on ask doc live
we'll be right back don't go away
all right thank you everybody i hope you
got up and stretched and got some of the
bodily fluids moving through your body
gotten a fresh glass of water want to
make sure that we're all staying
hydrated
there's so many benefits of staying
hydrated and i love being able to add
our plant derived minerals to all of our
all of my glasses of water so i'm
getting minerals throughout the day
in a way that the body can actually
absorb them so just one little hint of a
way that you can get extra minerals in
your diet
again we want to thank you and welcome
you for joining us on ask doc live my
name is rebecca kozak and
i am just honored to be able to
bring this program to you every week and
have it be a resource that you can use
to share with others to get the
information out about this alternative
road this journey that we're on
that is changing so many lives in such
an impactful way
and of course that's that's a positive
impact
for those of you who were
shared this program by somebody else get
back with them if you have any questions
or you are interested in getting
products
for those who
have not been referred to this program
by anybody specific
we do have a store at askdoclive.com
where you can find all of the products
that dr wallick is mentioning today
so we want to
make sure that you get the information
that you need and in order to make an
impact and choose that
more positive journey
on your life
that um
available to you
so dr wallach are you ready let's get to
the next hand
go ahead and have you unmute if you
would please
how's that that working
that works fantastic
okay
let's go to the next hand that is up and
that is peter
peter go ahead and unmute yourself if
you would please you are on live with dr
wallach
hi hi uh hi dr wallace we're here we're
here with uh mr paul
uh oh i'm hearing lots of noises
in yours okay
yeah but i was hearing like a zipper or
something like that okay so yeah paul's
here he just got out of the hospital
recently he paul has had his gallbladder
removed and uh recently he's had
swelling in his ankles swirling in his
ankles and he's turned jaundice so even
though he has uh got his gallbladder
removed um
his paperwork from the hospital he says
it shows um some
hepatitis and there could possibly be a
blockage in the the bilirubin too
okay
does he have any high blood pressure
diabetes arthritis
no
okay how much you weigh paul
about 165 170.
okay how tall are you six one
okay how old are you
69.
all right
let's see you have a little bit of gray
here there
do you have any varicose veins in your
legs
um
you used to have more but very little
now i don't have but i don't have very
many very little okay
all right uh any skin problems any
eczema dermatitis or psoriasis
no
okay
uh well i can see now
your beard is gray so i didn't even have
to ask the question okay
yeah
it's still kind of
brown
yeah if you have if you have one gray
hair you have gray hair okay okay
okay um
let's see here um do you have any kidney
issues are you are you on dialysis or
anything like that
nothing no not that i know oh
you'd know if you're on dialysis do you
have any um let's see here ringing in
your ears any tinnitus or ringing or
wishing or anything like that any
balance problems
no i do i do i do maybe
i do walk into walls or i'll be walking
and i kind of bump into the front of the
vehicle or something so is that from a
vision thing or is it a balance thing
i would think maybe a balance
mm-hmm
i don't go jumping off things that other
people jump off i'm i kind of want to
make sure i don't fall
sure okay good very smart all right
all right and so
also i'm sure he did i'm sorry dr molly
he does have uh he does have an issue
with uh urine flow and
prostate issues
okay
all right and then do you have any low
back stuff any sciatica something like
that low back stuff that's causing you
know like pain or numbness or tingling
in your toes and feet
no no no
sometimes a little bit of back pain but
no no numbness in my toes or my feet
okay yeah well most of the time when you
have trouble with urination it's a back
problem squeezing the sciatic nerve that
controls the bladder
all right
and so um here we go
uh once you get rid of all the bad foods
everybody in your
household cat no i don't eat a lot of
bad food i'm right okay well i've got 20
million people listening who have to
hear the same instructions
got it
all right
okay so i'm saying it for you but i'm
also giving it to them so so that
they're hearing the message too
all right so no bad foods no fried foods
no processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat broth ryan notice no sugar no
carbs or drinks even the diet one's got
to go
and then um at 165 170 pounds i want you
to take two healthy brain and heart
packs per month that's very important
because the healthy brain heart packs it
really should be called the healthy
brain heart liver kidney lung
pack okay
because
your liver requires an enormous amount
of nutrition the liver does like 40
different things the fact that you're
getting some jaundice here your eyes are
getting yellow or something like that
right uh do you have any anemia or low
white blood cells or low platelets you
get any bleeding under your skin
anything like that no
okay good i'll put this up i i cut i i
cut easy
you know my i guess old people's skin
will you
give you a bump into something or
okay so you do bruise easy okay
yeah and so your bone marrow is not
really happy okay because the bone
marrow makes the platelets to prevent
that sort of thing from happening so
we're going to deal with all that that's
a bone that's a bone marrow issue
all right which is important now because
it's your defenses also makes white
blood cells and antibodies your bone
marrow and if your bone marrow is not
working you're highly susceptible to the
covid
so we got to take care of you so none of
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no we
brought rhinos no sugar no carbonated
drinks then again
two healthy painted heart packs per
month i want you to take two bottles a
month of our msm so you can take three
with each meal
um that'll be
support and promote maintenance repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between the vertebrae now
that's going to help you with the
urination program here okay
also bone matrix and and so forth for
the bone marrow and then uh we also want
you to take
uh our gluco gel we have a liquid you
can take two quarts a month and take it
out twice a day uh or you can get
a bottle of our flexi care plus and take
an ounce of this twice a day okay you
can do that with this one bottle here um
and
uh it's going to replace the old um bone
broth we used to drink when we were a
kid
and uh then i also want you to take
um our ultimate daily classic tattoos
now this is for the leg swelling and um
so forth
and okay the
the healthy you see the ultimate daily
classic tablets still support healthy
blood flow through blocked arteries your
kidneys your heart your brain your eyes
your legs every place also in the veins
and um let's see here
that leg swelling we also have a product
called ultimate enzyme we call the
gallbladder in a bottle
it has bile in it from cattle you know
we go to the to the slaughterhouse we
take all the gallbladders from the cows
we dry the bile and we put some of that
bile in each of these ultimate enzymes
and i want you to take two of those
um before each meal like five or ten
minutes for each meal with a couple of
ounces of water so you'll need about two
bottles a month of our ultimate enzymes
to pull that off
and that's going to replace your
gallbladder which they took out
and um and so by taking all this stuff
this jaundice within
30 60 days should go away
and you should not have any pain you
know where you had
the pain where your gallbladder was
and this is a case where you need to be
sharing the story with your friends and
your church mates and all this kind of
stuff in your family
because
what should i say uh doctors removed
your gallbladder because you were
complaining about discomfort there
okay so that's why they took your
gallbladder out
and you got to stay away from the bad
foods because the odds are you at your
age you've been eating gluten you know
you've been eating oatmeal since you're
a year old and so you have a gluten
problem
and so this could be causing this pain
in this area also
but um
uh the urine flow should improve and if
you want something for your prostate we
do have we call prostafx you can take
three of those twice a day and that will
give your prostate gland what it needs
to function properly but also
to
[Music]
reduce the swelling so it goes back to
normal size it can function properly and
so forth it's called prost
p r o s t dash f x and wouldn't hurt
um shrink the prostate yes
that's correct as i said it'll bring it
down to its normal size a large prostate
yeah
it'll help the prostate function better
and so will the ultimate daily plastic
tablets which is this blood flow thing
and if you want to um you know this is a
male thing i take three of these twice a
day that's our it's our zera test it
gives us hertoli cells the raw materials
they need to make testosterone
i'd like to say something yeah put a
camera up there and that helped that
helped me uh go
go to the bathroom also i was
self-capitalizing myself i'm not doing
that anymore since i got out of the
hospital it seems like now i got a good
flow
okay good we're talking they're talking
about going in their roto-rooter opening
things up i don't really want to do that
procedure
okay so instead tell them no something
that can shrink my prostate
or what yeah i just i just told you that
it's the prostaff x
okay three of those twice a day there's
two vows a month i already told you
three times
do you have a hearing issue or a memory
issue
no i think i i got a bad hearing but i
think uh when people tell me something
it takes a minute to go
so i think i got a delayed uh
well
yeah
okay so yeah so all this including the
blood flow with the ultimate daily
classic catalyst is going to help your
brain work better don't forget the three
eggs twice a day but the prostaff x will
help also shrink the prostate gland
and um
i take three
of the process of x twice a day i take
three of the zero test
twice a day that's the raw materials to
make testosterone
and um you know i'm 82 years old and do
okay for an eight-year-old guy
all right so give us a call every couple
of weeks let us know how things are
going because you can see results very
quickly here uh
where do you see where do you live paul
i live in bellflower california born in
california okay so yeah you can get the
product within a couple of days very
easily but as soon as you hang up here
box up all the bad foods you may have in
the house
the fried foods the processed meats the
oils the glutens meatballs and sugar and
process and carbonated drinks
and you know give them to your doctor
don't just throw them away give them to
your doctor and deduct them all of your
taxes
okay so
guys i don't eat a lot of bad
i don't do bread i do meat free seldom
i'm i'm more into salads and vegetables
okay okay well let's back up here
you can be a meat-eater but you can't
eat it where it's burnt
medium-rare meat is good you know i eat
lamb chops every saturday night from
australia okay i steak every tuesday and
thursday nights i have gluten-free pizza
with hamburger patties on top of it four
types of different cheeses and six or
eight different vegetables
and of course the gluten-free pizza is
made with cauliflower and rice flour
okay
and um
i have a glass of wine
every night with my dinner i'll have a
third of a pint of gluten-free ice cream
for dessert every night i've been doing
this for like 74 years except for the
wine i just started the wine when i was
18.
okay and so anyway
basically
this is very simple
you give your body what it needs just
like when you go to the filling station
you check the air on your tires you
check your oil you check your antifreeze
you check your air filter all that kind
of stuff you just don't wax the car
when people you know they color their
hair and they put fingernail polish on
and they put makeup on this and the
other they don't take care of their
internal body and then they wonder why
they die at 35 or 50 or 70 or whatever
it is
we have the capacity to live well beyond
100 everybody in america
everybody in america
because of our education process and
ability to get things everybody in
america should be at least a super
centenarian which is 110.
everybody in america should live to be
110 so i always like to say my goal
is to add 25 to 50 healthy years
everybody's life right now the average
lifespan of americans is 75 it's dropped
four years
um since the pandemic is on because
people are dying in their middle ages
and younger ages
and so i want people to live to be
110 or more
and 25 to 50 healthier is your life but
you're going to have to work at it we
have the raw materials for you to do it
but you're going to have to incorporate
these raw materials into your life and
then stay away from the bad stuff
and then you'll add 25 to 50 healthy
years your life and give us a call every
two weeks bring us up to date because a
lot of people are going to want to hear
your story paul
all right thank you dr wallach
so next dr wallach
the lady with the hand up she's had some
really good questions
um in the comments so i'm looking
forward for her to be able to
get the information and answers directly
from you so kim thank you so much for
shooting yourself you are on live with
dr wallach my dear
this is kim kim yes god bless you dr
mark i love your faith and i thank you
so much for what you do
you're very sweet how can i help you
dear well i'm currently in the hospital
i've been diagnosed with multiple
myeloma palm syndrome lymphedema
hypothyroidism idiopathic intracranial
hypertension i've been on uh revlimid
i've been on revlimid for 71 months i
fell uh i fell about 13 weeks ago and uh
i i was knocked over by a door and i
okay stop
okay okay stop i want you to slowly go
over that whole list again start out in
the beginning multiple myeloma and then
you got two multiple myeloma palm
syndrome
no my sister had stopped
stop you say crohn's
poems p o p-o-e-m-s
syndrome
what is that
uh it's uh
it has multiple things it has idiopathic
mitocrania hypertension it's treated the
same way multiple myeloma is
it's a rare disease there's only like
500 people or so but it's growing
unfortunately
okay that tells me it's a nutritional
deficiency okay multiple myeloma okay
this is not a cancer in your bone marrow
is it
uh yes muscle myeloma is a cancer blood
cancer that affects your bones it
weakens them okay now back up back up do
you have any ring in your ears any tone
or tinnitus or whooshing in your ears
yes i had it terribly after surgery but
it's now gone
but i do periodically get it
okay
and do you have any high blood pressure
diabetes
uh it's difficult to tell because my um
results are skewed by my low hemoglobin
which is currently 8.2 i've had two um
i'm a type o negative and i've had two
transfusions right after my first
surgery on my femur no now wait a minute
now are doctors talking about you doing
a bone marrow transplant
uh no i have uh i have uh uh harvested
them but that's old technology and i
preferred not to do it only if uh um you
know if i have to just to survive i
would do it if i died
you know if your doctor said it you need
to flee
okay you do not need you did not no okay
good
okay
all right um
no high blood pressure no diabetes
i have a high blood pressure when i was
30 but not now and i can't tell if i
have diabetes because um my hemoglobin
is so low it skews the data however my
uh daily uh blood
glucose levels are good
okay
all right how much do you weigh
i was 426 today i'm probably about 253.
okay so oh you so you lost almost 200
pounds
yes i did it without surgery okay good
for you cool i walked in the pool seven
days a week
to uh two hours a day for seven months
uh back in 2012
and then i tried to uh just control my
calories to allow provide for a three
pound weight loss using uh an app
okay well here we go
um i'm going to just just go through
this and this will be posted so
um i don't expect you to get this all
written down okay yeah what you're
saying okay you're focusing on what i'm
saying and it's posted so you can look
at it 10 times a day for the next 100
years okay
okay here well here we go well
congratulations on losing that 200
pounds thank you i praise god it's all
god
well we he's the greatest healer isn't
he he is and the lord jesus christ
okay what a guy what a guy
i'm talking about jesus of course what a
guy yes beautiful beautiful i praise god
that i'm born again
okay good for you all right
um so i want you to give her again give
her all the bad foods what you're
obviously doing but this is for our
listening audience as well uh no fried
foods no processed meats no oils no
glutens no wheat no butter and oats no
sugar no carbonated drinks even the diet
one's got to go i want you to eat like
an asian eat rice and sweet potatoes and
beans and squash that kind of stuff
you can have fish you can have red meat
but nothing can be fried nothing can be
burnt
um you can even eat sushi you know you
know the japanese raw fish kind of stuff
if you're into that i swell when i eat
that uh i'm salt sensitive
okay
well you get sushi without salt on it i
see
okay
okay so anyway and then i want you to
take uh two healthy brained heart packs
for months two healthy brain and heart
packs a month to full dose everything
twice a day i want you to get two
bottles a month of our msm so you can
take three with each meal i want you to
take three breakfasts through it at
lunch for dinner time
and i want you to it's gonna help
support and promote maintenance repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue disc between the vertebrae bone
matrix which includes the bone marrow
cavity and all that kind of stuff it's
the support it needs and then
uh also will help you with the anemia
which you have
and let's see here
the tinnitus the ring in the ears also i
want you to get
um two bottles a month okay of the flexi
care plus
okay get two miles a month of this uh
put
one ounce of this in breakfast lunch and
dinner so that's why you need two miles
a month so you can take three ounces a
day instead of two ounces a day
of the flexi plus
okay
and um
that's going to give you
some more msm it's going to give you
some more collagen
and so on uh then i want you to take the
ultimate daily classic tablets ultimate
daily classic helmets once you take
three with each meal that's three
bottles a month it's gonna support and
promote healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries whether it's in the
brain or the heart or the kidneys it's
gonna support healthy blood pressure
and then do you ever get sleepy after a
meal you ever get sleepy after a meal no
but i am concerned because people with
multiple myeloma say we shouldn't have
hyaluronic acid or uh or glutamine and i
want to know if i should if i can follow
the guidelines in your cookbook for food
yeah
i was previously diagnosed with sleep
apnea and uh but i don't get sleepy
after a meal
okay good so you get yeah doctor while
he's cooking without the bad foods is
the book you want doctor cooking the bad
foods yeah yeah 300 pages of good
recipes that are gluten free and so on
so you'll love it if you like it quickly
i'm sorry to interrupt one other thing
is people who have multiple myeloma and
poems they're not supposed to have a lot
of protein because they can attach to
their organs um because it unfortunately
um
it can
attach to my organs i have to be very
careful i'm kidney sensitive
okay well everything we're doing here
supports the kidneys okay so give us
give us a call every couple of weeks or
every time you see the doctor and get
another report or something
and we'll walk you through this but get
this is where you're gonna get started
okay and again it's posted i don't
expect you to remember everything it
says posted
and so um
uh you know the girls do a great job of
putting it up and so you can get to it
and you can look at it a hundred times a
day but let's walk through this together
okay thank you i'm going to be in a
rehab so i may not be able to do it
until i get out because they control
what i'm able to take but i definitely
will proceed and i have been
implementing your dietary protocol well
here's what you're going to hear stop
here's this i want you to stop here's
what you're going to tell them i'm going
to find a a nursing home that's going to
let me take my vitamins and minerals if
you're not let me take my vitamins
minerals i'm out of here
i'm going to go to a different nursing
home i'm going to go to the nursing home
that lets me take the vitamins and
minerals yeah i'm being released today
and unfortunately with covered and
everything it's difficult to find a bed
particularly if you're a chemo patient
but i don't anticipate being there that
long so i'm gonna uh ask mike my doc i'm
going to ask both my doctors to please
let me take my supplements and they'll
turn into a purge order for me okay good
okay
thank you god bless you for all the
wonderful information okay god bless you
dear take care bye-bye
awesome thank you kim thank you for
having the courage to get on even while
you're in the hospital that's fabulous
and make sure that you do at the next
home you can request a gluten-free diet
so gluten-free and oil-free so that is
something that you can make sure that
you put in a request for
um dr wellick the next question is
coming from chibi tv's a little bit shy
so she doesn't want to come on with the
camera i apologize what's her name tb so
just the initials t
and b
like tuberculosis
yeah but i think it's much prettier than
that
um
so she the female 36 years old
327 pounds
and has been diagnosed with ealers
danios syndrome
and its comorbidities
okay if there was a piano playing or
something there for a moment
i don't know who did that
it's my internet oh okay okay so you had
to go back and what's what's your
problem ehlers
danlos
syndrome what is that
um that's a very good question and tb if
you would please come on and share the
symptoms that you are experiencing
that would be much much appreciated
so if you can unmute yourself
hello
all right go ahead share with us
what you're experiencing
um okay so
ehlers-danlos syndrome it's a
it's a connective tissue disorder
um
and it it literally
can affect your entire body so
um i also okay
thank you okay okay okay stop there a
minute now you say connective tissue
disorder are you talking about
disc problems between your vertebrae
you're talking about tendons and
ligaments so what are you talking about
here
um
it basically makes your
it makes your um
i'm sorry my brain
it makes
collagen your collagen
so
it can it can affect anything your
joints your
your
arteries your just anything
okay um so a lot of people get aneurysms
like right now i have uh i have a thing
called pots
which stuff makes my blood pressure okay
okay so your blood pressure drops okay
low okay low blood pressure do you have
any
diabetes i don't um
do you fall asleep after meals
oh gastroparesis okay so and so you have
you have uh
gastroparesis okay that's osteoporosis
of the skull squeezing the 10th cranial
nerve
of the vagus nerve causing pain in the
stomach
okay
and uh how tall are you
about five five
okay yeah five five i'd like to see
weigh 140 pounds
so we need to lose about 150 160 pounds
here
okay
and so um
uh here we go and i'm you know i'm just
going to go straight forward here but um
this will be posted so you'll be able to
you know go back to it many times
all right so you need to get rid of all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat no brighter eye notes no gluten no
weed nobody ryan notes no gluten no we
brought around notes because you have a
gluten problem do you have any skin
issues any eczema dermatitis or
psoriasis
um no but i have excessive dry skin
okay
do you have um
anything going on with your bowels any
constipation diarrhea irritable bowel
syndrome crohn's disease celiac disease
anything like that
i was diagnosed with ibs i also
have transfer
than the constipation
okay you had to back up
you said you're diagnosed with and you
had static there and i didn't hear what
you said oh sorry
um i was diagnosed with ibs
oh okay irritable syndrome okay yeah
that's a that's a gluten issue
everything you have
is caused by your gluten issue your
gluten issue
causes you not to be able to efficiently
absorb things all those villi in your
intestine go away instead of looking
like a shag rug your intestines look
like a smooth plastic tube you've lost
98 of your absorber surface and that's
why
all of your connective tissue whether
it's your arteries your tendons your
ligaments your cartilage your skin
everything is breaking down because you
can't get these nutrients
so you got to get rid of all the bad
foods okay then at 327 pounds
uh your age i would have you take three
of the healthy branded heart packs from
a month three health abandoned heart
fashion month full dose everything at
breakfast lunch and dinner
because you have some really
life-threatening diseases here
um and then
i want you to eat like an asian i want
you to eat rice and sweet potatoes and
beans and squash
uh you can have meat you can have fish
but nothing burnt nothing fried
um
i want you to eat eggs i want you eat
three eggs twice a day or two eggs three
times a day softball hard-boiled eggs
won't count and fried eggs will cause
cause cancer you want that
and then i also want you to in addition
to having the three healthy brain heart
packs per month uh photos everything
three times a day uh that's for many
things as for many things here uh
because there's like i don't know six or
eight different products in there and
just read the labels and it'll tell you
um the dosage but i'm telling you the
dosage
and then um for the gastroparesis i also
want you to take our ultimate enzymes
you can take two or three of those say
two five to ten minutes for each meal a
couple ounces of water
and then um
uh let's see here
okay well this is going to cover pretty
much everything you need
okay and that irritable bowel syndrome
will totally 100 go away but you got to
get rid of all the gluten no oatmeal for
breakfast
okay none of that kind of stuff
no wheaties for breakfast no pancakes
and waffles for breakfast
i had three big scoops of wild rice this
morning along with a couple of slices of
smoked uh wild elastic uh that elastic
wild
um
alaska salmon okay
and i had three soft poached eggs for
breakfast and i had some yogurt
and i had all my supplements
and so you can do the same thing i only
weigh 142 pounds
and
[Music]
you can eat about the same thing that i
eat
and you're going to
slowly i don't want to throw a weight
loss program at you yet i want you to do
this and get rid of the bad foods you're
going to lose a half a pound a day just
getting rid of all the bad boots
and so when you call me in two to four
weeks i expect you to be down to 300
pounds or
315 pounds or something like that you're
going to be losing a half a pound a day
if you do what i tell you here just by
getting rid of the bad foods okay give
us a call we'll walk you through this
and i'm going to have to look up um
a couple of these things because um but
i um
i know what you got
but they always like to these doctors
always like to name things after
themselves i'm gonna have to start
naming some stuff after myself
that's awesome dr wally
i want to do a quick screen share
because i have um
if it'll let me
oh it's not going to do it
um so i have this amazing graphic that
shows slides
of what it looks what your intestines
are supposed to look like okay good
and also what they're not supposed to
look like but it's not giving me this
screen option so i'm really bummed i'm
going to figure that out next time
okay but i just want people to know your
intestines your small intestines whether
you're doing surgery and you're opening
up the intestines because of surgery or
you're doing an autopsy and opening up
the testings intestines lining the small
intestine should look like a shag rug
should have these finger like villi
sticking up okay
and they increase your
absorptive surface by about 95 percent
uh when you're when you're eating gluten
those villi all go away and your
intestines now look like a plastic tube
you lost 98 of your absorbent surface
and that's where the problem comes in
now this doesn't happen overnight
this happens over a period of
months and years
and and when you're eating gluten three
times a day pancakes waffles oatmeal
then you have spaghetti at night in the
middle of the day you have flour
tortillas that kind of stuff and of
course you have
all kinds of desserts and cookies and
pie crust that kind of stuff
and you have cookies and cream ice cream
with the cookies in it you have cookies
for snacks
um
you drink beer made from wheat
you drink whiskey made from rye and
barley and
and
that sort of stuff
uh and so
uh
then
and say by the time you're 25 years old
you're going to have 25 different
diseases that are all nutritional
deficiencies diseases caused by a gluten
problem because you couldn't absorb the
nutrition even if you're supplementing
so yeah i'd love to have you show them
those pictures
oh i cannot hear you you're muted nope
sorry
so i'm going to get that figured out
before next time so that i can show this
graphic because it really does show that
shag rug and that hose effect when
gluten is
present
and has been used for so many years
so yeah well that's that's what killed
so many egyptians over those 10 plagues
in fif in 1550 bc
yeah
it's it's an it's very
impactful gives you a great visual so
i'll get that get that available
so
yes ma'am maybe you can have it posted
on ask doc live
i will do that i will do that i'll get
it inserted into the replay of this
video so that we can oh cool
yeah great idea
so christy dr wellick um made a comment
she says i started getting severe leg
cramps during the night not a charlie
horse much worse
i found it was caused by when i ate too
many mixed nuts which were raw unsalted
i do have food allergies but sometimes
it takes me a while to figure out what
causes
an effect
i used to hide the nuts from my husbands
so now i've given them all to him
now i know for me
my severe leg cramps
had to do with calcium and magnesium
magnesium and other mineral deficiencies
well rebecca you've hit a nail on the
head you get an a plus
and of course i would like to know how
much gluten christie's eating
okay because even if she's supplementing
the odds are she's eating gluten and she
can't absorb it and leg cramps is
usually due to nutritional deficiencies
uh causing because the muscles require
nutrients to to
contract and relax you need two
different nutrients to
contract and relax
and so leg cramps are quite common but
there could be
many many reasons for that
and so um
it's not because you're eating nuts
that's that's not the problem nuts
um are not the problem is because you're
having oatmeal for breakfast and
spaghetti three nights a week at
spaghetti factory and flour tarties at
lunch time and pizza three nights a week
made with flour
a pizza crust
that's the problem
yeah and so something else and this is
just a hint
for all of you parents and grandparents
out there you know
kids get growing pains
and i found that when i started my son
who's now nine
and almost as tall as i am at five foot
seven
um he no longer had those growing pains
and he's grown this year he's grown
almost five inches
but i started him on
adding additional osteo fx liquid dr
wallach well duh
so he sleeps better at night because we
give it to him at night and he doesn't
have any leg cramps
so i love the fact that that's
simple
addition into his diet has made such an
impact
well how do you feel that you know
something
that almost all doctors don't know
i stopped asking them for device advice
you
um
because
yeah it's it's so many things
i'll give them rebecca i'm going to give
the doctors the benefit of the doubt
here i'm going to think they're just
ignorant
and that's why they don't know what to
say because if they know what to say and
they're saying something wrong just to
get a patient then they're criminal so
i'll just i'll just say they just don't
know
there you go
all right
let's go to the
next hand that is up and that is susan
susan go ahead and unmute yourself you
are on with dr wallach
okay thank you
um female 68
i'm 114 pounds five foot nine and a half
i've shrunk uh one and three quarters
since my twenties
and my my presenting concerns clearly
from the bad foods diet in my youth but
i've been off gluten for some time and
so still dealing
with trying to get my my gut
working well and i and it feels like i
don't absorb water and nutrients
mine
are you supplementing with the 90
essential nutrients
uh just well i've just started with
yours but i have been
trying to focus on all of that
okay and then you're staying away from
wheat barley ryan oats there are no such
things as gluten-free oats yep well and
i've learned to take i was doing notes
but i've learned to take those out you
know no there's no such thing as
gluten-free oats that's a big lie yeah
and um because the gluten in oats is
called gliadin
and so you can call gasoline fuel but
it's still gasoline
called petroleum but it's still gasoline
right okay same principle here and so no
wheat butter oats and it takes you
uh
you're gonna you're gonna notice first
uh your hair color is gonna begin to
come back
are you getting you're starting to get
some what was your original hair color
blonde or red or brown or black or what
brown light brown
okay so you'll start seeing some brown
hairs coming back in
and you'll begin to get your hair color
back
and that'll tell you're absorbing the
nutrients
so
uh you don't need to take you know a
blood test although it wouldn't hurt if
you want to you can get our book um rare
earth and cures and do a hair analysis
in chapter 10 it tells you how to
collect the hair and how to box it up
where to ship it you know point size
check to put in there with it because
the lab won't run the test without the
check
and save you a lot of time by getting it
all in at once
and it has two charts when you do the
hair analysis one chart
tells you
about all the essential minerals are
they in the range where they're supposed
to be or some low some high uh what's
going on there
and then um
the second chart is toxic minerals
everybody said yeah when i was young i
was in the military and i know they
sprayed and all that kind of stuff so i
probably got some toxic minerals in it
well for a few bucks a day you can
find out exactly do you have any lead or
do you have any uh mercury do you have
any uranium do you have any of these
terrible minerals in there that people
always say i got them well well you know
for a little for a tax deductible lab
test
which is very cheap
i don't even remember
because i don't deal with it
but send a little check and it's tax
deductible because as part of your
health care
lab work
and
it's one of those things where
you can find out exactly do i have any
of those bad metals
and then of course
in our book man occurs it tells you what
to take if you have any bad metals it
tells you what to do if you're low and a
couple of nutrients if all of your good
minerals are low
guess what you're not absorbing
because you're eating gluten or you
thought you were gluten-free are you
cooking for your husband
no i live alone so i can i can really
control this okay for some time now okay
good so you're not cooking no gluten you
know other than a year ago getting rid
of the the gluten-free oats okay okay
good all right
so there you go and of course you at 114
pounds once you have one healthy brain
heart pack that's ours get another
bottle of our selenium one bottle of
slim will already be in there but i want
you to take three twice a day
um take a half of those everything else
twice a day uh 114 pounds for that one
healthy brand hard pack per month uh one
bottle of the msm so you can take three
twice a day or two three times a day for
total six a day and that will help um
repair the gut because a gut like your
arteries and veins is two-thirds of the
thickness is due to connective tissue
okay scar tissue not scar tissue but
connective tissue like tendons and
ligaments and that kind of stuff
and um
but this this will all go away and your
hair color will come back which is
telling you that you're on the right
trail and you're getting the nutrients
to your brain your eyes your heart your
kidneys your lungs your liver
they require an enormous amount of
nutrition to do their job just as we
were saying earlier on in the show your
heart beats
24 7 from the time you're conceived
until the time you're dead you got to
take care of that little puppy
most people take better care of their
dog than to take care of their heart
right
well this um it sounds like it'll all of
my presenting concerns from eczema to
low energy to starting to get bulging
veins is captured by that can i ask a
quick question about um
i'm taking the first prescription i've
had in about 40 years
and as far as
well i had a a cat bite that healed fine
but two days later i had a wasp sting
and quite painful foot swelled up
uh i
what i did dealt with the infection but
the foot stayed really large so
um
i went to critical care and came home
with a steroid
and how long ago was that um
wednesday so i'm only on three of six
days and i would the foot went down i
mean he said you know if the swelling
doesn't go down go to the emergency room
so i
um the swelling's down everything feels
normal to me i'd like to just stop this
prescription but it is one that says
take the full course
we've only got a couple of days left
take the full course but anyway by
taking the program that i gave you it's
always going to be good for blood
vessels veins arteries skin
tendons ligaments connective tissue
bones cartilage including your foot
okay
yeah yep good okay okay give us a call
every couple of weeks because people are
going to want to hear your story your
testimony will give people a lot of
um good information
okay bye-bye
awesome thank you so much susan next dr
wallach we are going to the next
hand up and
uh oh
the hand is up and there's a camera but
there is no audio attached to it
um
so there's no way that i can ask them to
unmute so um hi-lo
you are here with us uh you need to make
sure that you attach device audio
whenever you come into the zoom
so
um i do want to remind everybody that
you can get the replays to all of our
askdoc live
broadcasts at askdoclive.com
we have all that information there and
so many people were like what's that
good food bad foods list dr wally
just go through it so fast we have on
our website that list
so please go ahead and go to
askdoclive.com
right there in the menu options that
says bad food good foods list
and you can get that information there
you can also find all of dr wallach's
most popular
publications
on our astock live as well so one-stop
shop we've got all of the products that
dr wallach mentions but again get with
the person that invited you to this call
and
get
however whatever products you need order
through them okay
dr wellick
um pamela is asking a question
what causes hair loss like a handful a
day
and i
have been
there so i know the answer the solution
but let's get the solution directly from
your mouth which is going to be the same
thing that i used when i was having this
problem so
please okay thank you well hair loss has
to do with nutritional deficiencies of
the skin just like when you have
osteoporosis your bone structure it's
the nutritional deficiencies of your
bones okay and the same thing is true
with hair
we take people that have
been
bald for 40 years like a bowling ball i
mean smooth not one single hair on their
head for 40 years and in two months time
their hair is already a half inch thick
and in three months time their hair is
back like it was when they were 12 years
old uh original hair color no gray hair
all this kind of stuff um and so we like
to get rid of all the bad stuff again
none of the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat broth rhinos no sugar no
carbonated drinks and there's where
doctor walks cooking without the bad
foods is 300 pages of gluten-free
cooking
okay and recipes
with a combination of mine and
professional chefs is really a really a
good investment for your health
and then
um
you want the healthy brain and heart
pack one healthy brain and heart pack
per 100 pounds of body weight by
throwing the msm for collagen okay which
is skin
and then we have the hair skin and nails
my favorite i take three of those twice
a day hair skin and nails
there's two bottles a month
and it gives your skin what it needs to
make hair
but you also need to have circulation so
you need the ultimate daily classic
tablets through those twice a day for
100 pounds of body weight
and the hair will grow back
and
if it started falling out
white gray and silver
again within a couple of months the hair
color is coming back because
white grand silver hair is not an age
thing
it is in fact a
a nutritional deficiency it's a red
warning light that you're going to have
some more serious life-threatening
problems down the line so getting your
hair to grow back within with your hair
color when you're a kid that's a very
good sign that you're on the right track
all right thank you so much for sharing
that um now
the next question that i have is from
somebody who is experiencing
urinary tract infections
that they just can't get rid of so this
is a female she's 46 years old
and weighs 178 pounds at 5 foot four
she has never done any of your products
and her main concern when she was
writing it was trying to get rid of
these painful urinary tract infections
okay
well the odds are it's a back problem
okay causing pain on urination
okay
um and so this can happen in men and
women but in a woman she doesn't have to
worry about a prostate issue
okay
so that's that's fair
and so at 178 pounds you get rid of all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no gluten no
wheat bread right no sugar no carbonated
drinks even the diet ones
but 178 pounds
i want her to take two healthy abandoned
heart packs for a month to full roast
everything twice a day i wanted to take
two bowels a month of our msm take three
of those with each meal and they're
going to support and promote managed
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between a
vertebrae very important here because
when you have sciatica
low back issues
the vertebrae get closer together they
smash the sciatic nerves which control
the urinary bladder
very difficult to start urination very
painful urination
and doctors focus
on your pelvis
when it's really your back
okay and so
you can also in case you have an
infection
in case you do have an infection we have
our colloidal silver you put two
droppers full under your tongue 30
minutes for each meal and 30 minutes
before bedtime that'll kill just about
everything viruses bacteria fungus and
yeast um because it
absorbs through your mouth your oral
tissue is almost like intravenous it
never reaches your stomach because it
just is absorbed very quickly it has no
taste it tastes like water
there's no alcohol in it so even little
babies can have it
colloidal silver
for internal infections
and so i would guess
that
this is a back issue as opposed to
urinary tract infections
all right okay
now i i just had a comment come in
wanting to know what would you recommend
for a 12 year old girl 140 pounds she
started getting urinary tract infections
when she was two years old
that's
that's a long
time yeah yeah well again
um is it a back problem there's no
reason why a two-year-old can't get a
back problem if the two-year-olds eating
oatmeal for breakfast
and not taking any supplements are
getting droppers full of vitamin a kind
of thing you know
and having a very pitiful this is where
these kids need the kids toddy
all right and the efas
and you can throw in the
pollen burst chewies
oh chews okay because they get the efas
from the sunflowers so i know there's no
gluten in there because efas come from
the sunflower seeds
so that's very safe for kids
and
this
is
very very simple um probably 98 of the
reason that people go to doctors far
is undiagnosed nutritional deficiencies
almost always secondary to
a gluten issue malabsorption and not
supplementing
and so you get them supplementing you
get them off the gluten
and all these problems that people have
had for weeks and months and years and
half a lifetime
go away in weeks
because i mean i get people who are
unconscious being fed through a g-tube
three times a day you know through their
belly um for eight years we give them
our stuff through the g-tube and three
days time they get up and go back to
work they didn't even realize they're in
a coma for eight years
and and so it's um
this i do this all the time i have
pastors that were you know their family
and their church family were told they
only had weeks to live
um they're in a coma and we we just
rubbed our plant minerals because they
didn't they weren't being fed through g2
because they didn't think they were just
going to survive so they didn't even
give them a jitter they're just just
give him an iv to keep him hydrated and
slowly drying up and dying
and so
miss linda one of our great distributors
in baltimore maryland she you know her
and she um wipes these minerals all over
the pasture on his back and his legs
just our plant minerals are you know
our um
colloidal minerals
three days time he wakes up goes back to
his church and he's
through his studio he's
zooming and talking to everybody all
over the world how this miracle happened
and uh i flew out there and we did a cd
and a dvd it's called praise the lord
and pass to 90.
praise the lord in passing 90 we tell
his story
and many other stories similar to his
and it's kind of like if you're in the
military you know where that came from
because uh god is there does a great job
but when somebody's shooting at you you
want ammunition to shoot back so in the
military it's praise the lord but pass
the ammunition
right in this case it was praise the
lord and pass the 90.
i love that i love that because you know
there is
so much life
in that 90
that people don't even realize
what they're missing until they get it
into their bodies
i just
and that's something that i experienced
um you know i had had migraines dr
wallach since i was eight years old wow
and
within the first two weeks of getting on
your program
those migraines quit
and in the last five years i've had
maybe
four
headaches
that when i wouldn't even classify as a
migraine
and it's just because
of the nutrition
that i found in your products
that i had gotten nowhere else
thanks for sharing your testimony
well and you know whenever the doctors
say okay well you can't take this you
can't take this there's not enough money
in the research to find out what the
cause is
is for me it's just
ridiculous because you've already done
that research
and we have a solution
yeah that's
in the smithsonian institute as a
national treasure that's my thesis on my
20 000 autopsies it's in the
smithsonian's national treasure they
can't say it's not available
right
it's it is available they just
they can even go online by they can buy
used copies fairly economically
well it's see it's it's the wrong people
educating them dr wallach
well there you go
so we just need to make sure that your
message gets out more and more and all
of you that are on live with us today
everybody that's watching this replay
join us in making sure this message gets
heard
share it with everybody you know
whether they're in or out of the medical
field it does not
matter let's get the truth out there and
start taking back our health
it's
well said
it's so simple dr wallach but people
make it complicated
so i just i
want to encourage people to give give
your website out give your website out
again so you can get the books and cds
dvds
yes go to askdoclive.com
ask askdoclive.com
all one word no spaces no periods no
hyphens
just
the letters
and you'll be able to find all of dr
wallach's publications you will find a
store there with all the products that
dr wallach has mentioned today
and you have the contact us option where
you can send us an email with your
questions
in regards to health and one of our
certified holistic health coaches will
respond to that making sure that you get
just what you need
we don't try to sell you something more
but just what you need to help your body
do what it's designed to do so
i just want to thank you we are straight
up top of the hour
i just looked at the top
well now it's channel one that's right
that's right
um but dr wallach thank you so much and
ruth ellen thank you so much for all you
do as the co-host um she and i were kind
of on
doubling it today rather than having our
our extra double with us but i think it
went smoothly
you did a great job
yeah we just we we loved what we do dr
wallach and the fact that we can share
this message with others
and have purpose in what we do is
probably one of the greatest rewards
well your family we're family thank you
thank you ruth ellen
thank you dr wong thank you becca and
thank you everyone for coming it was
great that you could join us today
absolutely and we will see you next week
same place same time okay bye-bye
we'll talk to you later bye dr wallach
bye-bye everyone
bye-bye